welcome back to new rockstars with
she-hulk episode 3 introducing a light
elf doing a secret invasion and a
wrecking crew who turned an asgardian
bomb the builder into robbed the builder
new asgard is certainly affecting the
world with their superpowered presence
on midgard but what if i told you that
this third episode of she-hulk was more
than just an excuse to make megan the
stallions twerking mcu cannon what if
the mcu is actually setting up the
grounds for an all-out siege on
valkyrie's new asgard this is rogue
theory the show where we pitch the
wildest theories for the nerdy titles
that we love my name is mt and going
world with me today is new asgard's
secretary of defense herself it's
jessica clemons what's going on jess um
i'm doing it i'm doing it i'm doing it
i'm doing it well
that's the only way you represent queens
he was raised out of brooklyn
i i always know he can help me i dig it
um and also we have ourselves the only
person on this planet capable of lifting
mjolnir it's whitney van lineham what's
going on oh wow yeah look at these guns
welcome to the gun show baby
me and thor no i am so
skinny like my arms are like a little
chicken it's all about worthiness okay
it's all about the worthiness it's not
about the heaviness
i don't work out i'm sorry same it hurts
and it makes me sweat which also hurts
and also i hate oh sorry it's the worst
sweating i think should be illegal um
when i'm president i will outlaw
sweating thank god um thank you
immediately thank you god bless that
and the only man who can give megan the
stallions twerking ability a run for its
money it's tommy bech told what's going
on tommy uh
not a lot of teeth thanks for asking big
head gang
uh speeches
uh my question is who do you love
because i wanna lounge with you are you
for sure i do what i gotta do who do you
love
me
are you for sure
this is true i love i love a good call
back i love a good lyric
thank you toby i love you brother um but
this leads us to our first topic of
today
root of the elf will be canceled for
wearing black face twice just kidding um
she didn't wear black face two times
that episode
i literally didn't even think about that
but then again i'm translucent so yeah
damn that's crazy i did not even think
about
i think the mcu is straight up preparing
a siege on new asgard with this third
episode of she-hulk this is why i think
this because something is going on with
glk and h i don't trust holloway with
anything i wouldn't trust all the way to
open a door for me something is going on
with holloway and i think that these
nefarious force i most likely val and i
think hydra are sort of trying to
prepare the society for viewing new
asgard in a bad light because we had
this whole gore the god butcher thing
happened and like that sort of brought a
lot of attention and a threat to earth
then we have um
this light elf impersonating people and
like you know sort of making people
untrustworthy of other people a little
bit before secret invasion anyway and we
also have the wrecking crew who stole
some stuff from an asgardian and is now
terrorizing new york city with their uh
w shirts um all synchronized um very
cute uh but i think that this is the mcu
sort of laying the groundwork for
potentially um just having law cases
being like oh yeah as guardians did this
as guardians did that we have to invade
asgard for their oil we have to do it
just kidding for their energy um so i
think that um val and uh holloway and
whoever is working with val are trying
to paint new asgard bad so they can
invade asgard for all their sweet energy
what do you guys think yeah i like that
uh they have weapons of asgardian
destruction there and we've gotta we've
gotta find all the wads before uh
before the bad guys can take us i think
that's all those wads get
[Laughter]
uh
we're being littered with some
anti-asgardian propaganda here and uh
perhaps a siege
maybe perhaps a a uh a turning on and
and a uh
a good old-fashioned uh
uh limiting of power by like have the
asgardians gotten too powerful are they
a threat you know you know we know the
mcu and marvel comics parallel
kind of real world issues so yeah i
totally think that's feasible yeah man
and like also the we got to bring up the
siege comic on the comic event in the
marvel comics where um norman osborne
literally attacks new asgard um during
the dark rain period with the help of
the century and uh because he just
manufactures a crisis that gives him the
permission to invade new asgard yeah so
yeah um i definitely feel like well he
certainly
was gorgeous i didn't know about that
one i don't think i've read that one
that sounds like oh it's it's literally
[ __ ] the very end of dark rain it's it's
so much fun it's crazy
oh [ __ ] that's right is he
his
norman
patriot yeah his number osbourne has
iron patriot how cool he was uh doing
all this crazy [ __ ] oh god it's
literally one of my like the best norman
osborne story in my opinion like no
that's no sick i gotta go ready
i'm gonna hang up this call and go read
that because that sounds dope i'm not
gonna lie you gotta at first i was like
i don't know i might i might go ogus on
this but now i'm like oh [ __ ] that
sounds very [ __ ] cool actually and
now i i i believe you and i want this to
happen so bad alright
what do you think jess um
[Laughter]
[Music]
tommy shut up
i miss you jessica
i miss you tommy come back because when
you come back i'm gonna be gone um
i like it
i think it's factual i think it's sound
but is it crazy oh how crazy tell me if
you think it's crazy empty of being a
mom being a black mom tell me what you
think tell me if you think that makes
sense
i mean okay from from the outside
looking in
um like knowing the siege event and like
knowing how like big it was in the
marvel comics i guess it's not
completely crazy because like when you
when new asgard is on earth and like if
new zealand is gonna be on earth you
might as well do a siege because like
they're not gonna be on earth forever
most likely like asgard's probably gonna
come back and they're probably gonna
peace out so um i feel like it's just it
makes sense for marvel studios to sort
of like take the advantage of like all
right let's just fight them real quick
and then have him leave
but um i don't know i guess my follow-up
question is so you think that could
still happen even though new asgard is
in norway do you think how close do you
think the jurisdiction of what norway is
putting out is also protecting what is
new asgard now because i i guess in
in thor love and thunder norway did not
care at all that they were getting
attacked by gore but
do you think it would be going away am i
right
oh
[ __ ] he was about to turn norway into
norway
[Music]
there you go thank you that that's what
i was gonna say and i was like i don't
even know who sings that song
anyways
oh i'm sorry oh oh i'm sorry that i
forgot limb biscuit no no no no no i'm
gonna forget biscuits
please i was thinking of mushrooms my
way
i'm going on a spotify right now looking
at blimp biscuit
immediately we need to open up this
episode with lin biscuit just kidding
absolutely not it should only be open up
with kid rock and kid rock only oh it's
like the
bavarian version of limp bizkit i'm
sorry are they not the same person
um
tommy i'm going to strangle you myself
oh my god
we can't play
yeah they were attacked by gore but they
weren't seized by gore so i think
seizing an actual city within a country
that's already like
is norway is a different story does that
make sense so uh do you think norway
won't actually put up in like a fight i
guess norway's usually never gonna fight
but you know sweden is neutral norway
will get dirty they don't care norway
doesn't care okay
refugees they don't know
those trolls up in the mountains man
they're ready to rock they do
creatures
our army is all fantasy
yes
into it so with captain america new
world order coming up we know that's
gonna be a big phase five title i think
that a new world order will be set up
like that sort of paying superhumans in
a bad way in particular on the people of
asgard so i think that norway might be
like you know what i want to be safe
like i'm so scared of all these
asgardians like you got to get rid of
them for us man like we just want to be
norway again um so i think that um
there's a chance there um that we could
see the united states invade norway with
norway's permission um to get new asgard
johnny manning's heading on down
he said i did my 23andme here i go boom
here i
oh my god he's speeding but no i can
totally see like the thunderbolts having
to fight valkyrie and like all these as
guardians um in in a fight and i really
want to see them get their butts kicked
by valkyrie because
dockery don't play around you don't you
really don't all right i'll give you
i'll give you a rogue gift i'll give you
a rogue because you stand up you stood
for your theory
oh you know what honestly it's been a
minute in the venomous theory maybe i'm
just confused
let's move on quickly let's get let's
keep this rolling
keep going before jess changes their
mind
we've been pumping carbon monoxide in
jessica's home this whole time
i might be honest
[Laughter]
okay so i get a rogue is from tommy as
well yeah what in i'm like sue big what
do you think windy and a rogue is i
already told you
i voted early early voter registration
here my goodness i love all of you wow
goodness i pull this theory out of my
i'm just gonna
be by the way
my way on the highway
hey
it's your way of the gore way we went
over this jeez
but no i i really do think that the
marvel studios is heading in this
direction because it would just be
really fun and i feel like
if you're gonna do secret wars wars is
plural okay we gotta see
what's going on you guys have one secret
one war you gotta have many secrets
awards it's easy there's gotta be give
me
give me two dozen wars i wanna i wanna
exactly you guys more and more yeah
life is just too peaceful and too calm i
need some conflict i need i need so much
more conflict just like
everything has been so boring in the
last four or five years right
no i was about to say that is complete
white behavior of umt and i need you to
suck
down
not here not today we're not in
september
earth wind and fire is just starting
it's about to hit you better
but that is uh that's just my theory up
next jess has a really interesting
theory of her own um that we cannot wait
to hear but first be sure to check out
new rockstars.com where right now we are
currently have two latest obsession
shirts two can you believe it two at the
same time we had to hack the servers to
make it happen and we made it happen our
first one is lady justice do you like
ladies and justice good for you because
this is expired by the she-hulk series
and there's a ton of other merch based
on she-hulk that you can find on the
site but our secular substitution shirt
comes from the way of the land of
westeros and it's called ash and ruin
which is what i look like before i put
lotion on his inspired box oh my god oh
my god i hate you
that was so funny
i'm ridiculous it is inspired by the
house of the dragon on hbo max have you
seen it there's a lot of genitals on
there probably so be the one who rules
your nerd kingdom and show off your ash
and ruin shirt to warn anyone who dares
threaten your reign because if anyone
wants you to get off the couch you have
to fight them with your with your ash
and ruined shirt on because that is your
throne don't let anyone take your throw
so both of these shirts are limited
edition and won't be available for long
and when you purchase either of these
shirts you unlock the ability to get a
custom shout out that will appear on the
after show for our respective shirt
series so support the channel and check
out all of our awesome merch options
over at newrockstarsmerch.com
hi whitney van laningham and tommy
bechtold here from hello today we would
like to let you know about a new product
that uh new rockstars highly endorses
diapers for parakeets yes
your birds just [ __ ] too much the bottom
of the cage you always gotta you always
gotta take it out dump it out and it's
not like kitty litter where like you can
sort of pick it's just all poop all the
time everywhere introducing diapers for
parakeets little hole in the back tail
goes through tommy take it take it from
here what else do you get
polly
yes she does
and right now our rogue theory listeners
can get 98 off by typing in the code
lizard people control the government 20.
98 off
diapers for parakeets uh using the code
lizard people control the government and
we want to thank our other sponsor today
uh westchester farms donkey pepperoni uh
don't make until you try it
i've tried a lot of pepperonis in my
life but the best pepperoni i ever had
was made from ground up donkeys that
have committed crimes against other
donkeys at westchester farms they
believe an eye for an eye and an ass for
an ass and that's why they executed
criminal donkeys and turned them into
pepperoni wendy you recently tried some
donkey pepperoni oh i sure did you know
what i just went to the most beautiful
wedding last weekend at westchester
farms and they have what's called a char
not so cutery plate and this is where
all of the ground up donkey pepperoni
yes is just slabbed out and it gets a
little greasy in the sun you know what i
mean when it's like a little greasy
little clammy but that's the best
part that's right that's what it smells
the best sweat off the donkey salami
it's still a donkey pepperoni i'm so
excited you know what that was a
freudian slip but we'd like to announce
now making donkeys donkey salami
remember westchester farms that's not a
tooth sometimes donkeys just have too
many bones in them
use use code wow donk pap 20
to receive 200 off your next order
don't pack 20. they'll actually mail you
back a check for the amount you were
going to spend
right now
you get free money and free donkey parts
amazing
westchester donkey pepperoni where their
pronouns are always hee-haw
oh my god
i'm so done with you
oh my goodness all right
okay
you know what i hope we never have ads
again so we can just do this every time
this is hilarious
um okay
now it is time for our second part of
the episode take it away jess with your
second theory
so
[Music]
here is my second theory
i'm ready i hope you guys are ready my
body is ready i know you guys are so
ready for this series okay so
my theory is
i i came prepared shut up you guys uh
why the leader is the leader of the
wrecking crew so
i i can't i asked empty if i could do
this theory yesterday and i did not know
that we were gonna get a video adjacent
to this on the channel soon probably
before this video comes out so you know
uh you can you can choose who you like
more i know it's gonna be eric voss but
i'm gonna say my theory regardless uh so
uh i put my notes in my slack app so i
have to keep referring back to this okay
so these are the reasons why i think the
leader is gonna be the leader of the
wrecking crew that we see going forward
aka
number one his name's the leader
he's meant to lead someone uh marvel
could have turned him into the villain
the leader after the incredible hulk and
give him his origin story later or in
short and she-hulk okay so yeah so we
haven't seen the leader since incredible
hulk i think there's a wide opening for
them to make up any theory they want to
what he was doing and i think she-hulk
is already creating their own narrative
with everything saying that uh the
wolverines here uh putting megan the
stallion in so why not just give them
his own backstory i mean we just got
emil blonsky who could have been doing
everything under the sun so why not just
take the leader as well and give him a
backstory uh the the leader also has
worked with the wrecking crew in the
comic books and i also think that the
wrecking crew wouldn't want to work for
someone like val because
vice versa val is not as messy as the
wrecking crew the wrecking crew is the
lamest group of villains
i love what are you talking about they
were so professional we talked about
this marvel if you show up as a villain
team with your own uniforms that's one
thing but screen printed t-shirts that
are w with an o around it that's another
that is a soccer team's jersey fans of
if they whitney that they were fans of
whitney then i would be like oh you guys
did really good but because there's you
guys
announce yourself on your uniforms when
you're trying to jump a superhero and
you're a normal person that's me walking
up to someone and being like give me
your money we're in a new rockstar shirt
like this yes 100 yeah
imagine she saw the shirts and she was
like whitney sent you i knew it
again i'm like you pay me like
like you know where i'm coming from so
that's why i'm like they're such a messy
team they will not be working for val
val is not that messy wilson fist just
got out of prison like why would he want
to work with a team just as messy as the
jumpsuit mafia from hawkeye i think he's
probably like i don't want any more mess
i think the leader would make the most
sense because if we are doing his like
little short origin story this could
give way to like he's just now coming up
he's just coming up right this is the
first team he could get also he probably
learned them by offering them a piece of
the she-hulk's gamma blood because they
just are using the asgard and weapons
why not use actual yourself
and so i think they're gonna he's like
i'll give you some of this blood and you
can be a hulk as well and they're like
okay we'll do it and they're messing up
the job they are
messing it up completely um what else
did i say oh yeah he's still obsessed
with bruce's blood and bruce is now gone
right so why not take she-hulk's i think
that'd be the next person to further the
evolution of the hulks so he's probably
like okay i don't know where the hell
this this green giant is but i can find
she-hulk and i'm gonna take her blood
and i'm gonna use it for my own my own
being so i do think ultimately it has to
be someone sloppy that's working for the
wrecking crew and i think that only
person could probably be the leader
um that's all my notes say
and i don't know if the like if the
leader even knows it but like obviously
she hulk's blood is kind of technically
superior to bruce's it absolutely is
like bruce still has bpd
and uh she-hulk can twerk to megan the
stallion so like who's doing better you
know like i think
i think that it's probably she-hulk um
no that totally makes sense that's
[ __ ] great i like that jessica
in my life as your as your friend uh i
have never been more impressed and
agreed wholeheartedly with a theory of
yours the leader and if you are the
leader i'm following
i'm following and i'm loving every
second you're following
i i give i give you ten roguses i got
every i give you all these hands up
us up
hey thank you thank you jessica's the
leader and she passed out everyone i
love whitney t-shirts because yeah
everybody's got a white t-shirt
i want one
of boston jeez
but no i i love the fact that you
brought up um the the wrecking crew
they're goofs now like they're they have
these as guardian weapons but like they
don't have the asgardian strength to
wield these weapons and so like
i think that like in the comics like
these guys are super swol they're super
strong and like they can mess things up
i think that like the leader giving them
that gamma power power will make them a
much more bigger threat to the mcu and
like less goofy so um and like i feel
like you know we saw in [ __ ] the
winter soldier that there is like a way
to give people powers without making
them super jacked and swole so like
these actors don't have to get super
strong they could just all right i have
gamma power now
just it just it's just implied so uh
yeah no it just makes a lot of sense for
them to uh be stronger and like the only
way for them to do that now that all the
super soldier serum is gone is to go
gamma so yeah
you gotta go gamma baby
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
oh okay so now we have johnny manny's
and yo gamba gamma
the star villains
phase five will never be the same uh but
no i i really like i've been like try
preaching the leader for the longest
time because that dude's coming back you
can't set up a four-headed man a big
four five-headed six-headed man um and
not to bring him back to the mcu i hope
it's the same actor because i love that
actor but i can understand why uh if he
didn't want to come back to uh doing
comic book movies because he was also in
the fantastic four movie from 2015 that
uh people don't talk about um so well
he's also in holes
he's also buster scruggs he's awesome
every southern
my favorite mcu show
unbreakable
[Music]
so i think i i pitched i pitched some i
pitched this
and then i also uh in my head was like
he also could just be dead i really hope
that's not the case but it's like
everybody he took the
hulk's blood and it was that bad and it
killed him uh my second theory was this
could also be leapfrog's crew and i
stand by it if it turns out to be
leapfrog's crew i'm gonna i'm gonna have
a heart attack i'm gonna be so into it i
think leapfrog deserves a bunch of goons
and i think he's gonna be a villain i
don't think he's actually gonna be a
good person
um yeah i i agree
yeah sidenote sorry
i really do think i agree with you that
leapfrog is probably going to be a
villain at the very start of she-hulk
when he debuts because of his father
because we know in the trailer um and
this is just to be assuming the guy that
jumps out of the window and lands on the
car i think was the original you think
he's the dad
yeah i think that that's his dad oh yeah
like he does that same exact thing in
the comics he jumps through a window and
he lands on the street um so i think
that
he breaks his ankles in the comedy no
he's still man everyone knows he doesn't
okay no he doesn't that's how he exits
buildings
he's like oh you can't prove that those
springy shoes are mine and they're like
oh yeah put them on and he puts them on
me jumps through the window to try to
escape exactly he breaks his ankles and
stillman is like hey you're just as
useless as me let's team up
let me help you
anyway uh but you know
we see in the trailer that um
this um who i assume is leapfrog's dad
he jumps out the window and he lands
perfectly fine so like something about
his physiology is different than
somebody else's i think that
his dad might be like gamma powered
potentially who knows but all right it's
time for voting time what do you guys
think of this idea of the leader being
the secret nefarious force that's once a
little bit of that jennifer walters
blood what do you guys think about this
oh hell yeah i wrote this all the way
whoop we got a rogue is from tommy we
got a rogus from whitney and what does
mt think i'm going to give this
i want to give this an ogus because it's
very likely
it's likely okay
okay okay i'll give it like a rogue and
an august
whatever oh i'm like halfway through
because like you know what i think it's
very likely i think that you're right on
the money i think you're right on the
money which like which means that like i
believe in your theory but like actually
no you know what i'll just give it a
full on rogue because like why not
bully my wife
uh
but now it is time for our rogue
question are you guys ready for this one
so ready ready all right
get ready because here it comes because
in honor of labor day weekend give me
your rogues hero or villain that you
would invite over for the labor day
barbecue and what dish would they bring
with them i would bring frank castle aka
the punisher
and the dish he would bring is a dish
best served cold the dish of revenge
a dead person
everyone is dead i would have him i
would invite all my enemies to a labor
day picnic and then frank castle would
show up last and he'd mow them all down
[Laughter]
you know what that's not a bad way to do
it because frank castle he's not all
there
no two birds of one still actually no
you just get rid of all your problems
there you go that's right um but what do
you guys think i'm going to invite
johnny mayonnaise specifically
because you know what he's bringing he's
bringing a donkey pepperoni yeah
[Laughter]
it's gonna have like the really gross
cheese that like even when you take the
plastic off it still kind of tastes like
plastic that's what's gonna be on and
then white bread just like white bread
that's just the whitest bread yeah the
whitest bread
you can find slathered in mayonnaise
slapped with donkey pepperoni and why
would you break with plastic cheese
his arch enemy aunt jemima sorry that's
really fun
no no keep going keep going
what you got jessica um
[Music]
i probably like him by megan the
stallion because now she's a hero in the
marvel cinematic universe it's true yeah
always wanted to hang out with her
and we'd eat like um
a vegan
a vegan sushi roll because she loves
vegan food and sushi
and a nice like
sauvignon blanc um and for dessert that
ass
wow
[Music]
[Laughter]
there you go
but no um i love all of these of course
as who would i bring um i think it would
probably bring up either frog man
or kate bishop probably you are gonna
bring kate bishop let's be real come on
it's gonna be king bishop um because for
no reason
exact same sequence of events
like it's not a nice date it was i said
we're gonna have a nice sushi dinner
nice one yeah of course yeah just finish
it up with some ass
sushi and ass my favorite combination um
but anyway no i love all these theories
but i'm gonna have to give the rogue
question award to jessica just in honor
for megan the stallion this is megan the
stallion season beautiful so she's into
the new mcu hero we gotta we gotta
recognize we gotta pay respect so
jessica is our rogue question winner for
today
claps for jessica haram claps in the
chat haram horror
class claps in the chat in the chat
clap's in the chat clap's also claps
everywhere claps in the seat claps in
the chat clapping ass claps in the
cheeks i didn't i was gonna say it but i
was like i don't know if i can't
you can clap your own ass empty
everyone
out there i did suggest that we open
this episode of rogue theory not with
our bright shining faces but with our
twerking butts i did make that
suggestion and you know who shot it down
the government as they always do the
poor police
they made it illegal and it made me sad
disgusting disgusting but yes
next episode we can open with twerking
uh i'll try to make it happen but that
is it for this episode of rogue theory
thanks to our amazing guest jessica
clemons wendy van lenningham and tommy
bechtold go follow them on all their
social medias they're amazing people you
can um but also you can support our
channel by checking out all of our
awesome merch over at new
rockstarsmerch.com we have amazing
shirts inspired by she-hulk and house of
the dragon pick them up today and if
you've got thoughts on some of our rogue
theories you can share them on our
discord so if you're over 18 click the
link for the new rockstars discord
server in the description box below this
video and join the conversation you can
follow me at mass entertainment if you
want to see me tweet some weird [ __ ] you
can follow new rockstars and all social
platforms and be sure to subscribe to
our channel here on youtube we love you
guys so much thank you guys for for
joining us being goofy and weird and
super dirty we love you and we'll see
you guys next time goodbye
[Music]
you